[Musique]
quatorze formations d'écoles militaires
ouvriront le défilé des troupes à pied
cette année pour la majeure partie des
effectifs ce 14 juillet 2019 sera donc
une première c'est une belle surprise
déjà est un grand honneur parce que
j'étais loin d'imaginer il ya quelques
mois de faire le 14 juillet et surtout
en école ce n'est pas un hasard si les
troupes à pied répète sur le site
militaire de satory
ils présentent quasiment les mêmes
caractéristiques techniques que les
champs elysées une piste rectiligne qui
reproduit la ligne d'éclatement devant
les tribunes
[Musique]
avec sans cesse pas par minute la
concentration le sérieux sont de rigueur
chaque troupe est minutieusement
observés durant les entraînements
le gant de boxe vont pourvoir difficulté
c'est qu'ici on veut la perfection au
niveau de tous qui alignement au niveau
de tout ce qui est cadencement balancier
essaie de tendre sur cette perfection
c'est vrai que c'est un peu plus
contraignant que ce qu'on fera régiment
mais ces deux largement atteignable et
le but c'est d'être parfait pour que le
défilé qui sera réalisée soignants soit
impeccable 4299 femmes et hommes
descendront la plus belle avenue du
monde cette année
parmi eux que des yvelinois revenir à
satory hier des entraînements pour être
au niveau en arrivant à satory est ici à
satory voilà on fait dans la correction
répétition activement ce n'est fier
parce que c'est que la famille va
regarder
j'espère que ça va bien se passer on est
fier c'est un honneur d'être des tritiée
pour le défilé du 14 juillet cette année
le défilé du 14 juillet est placée sous
le signe de la coopération européenne
l'allemagne ou encore l'espagne seront
représentés
[Musique]